fantastic the solution for this is
pretty straightforward based upon what
we've already seen firstly we walk
through all of the tile sets inside of
the map object that we've created for
each one of them we create a new image
set its onload function and then set its
source name once we're loaded
effectively we increment the image load
count variable and then we test whether
or not the image load count variable is
equal to the number of tile sets that
could potentially occur so effectively
we're saying our number of images loaded
equal to number of images that exist if
so we can set fully loaded equal to true
now you'll notice one annoying little
variance of the JSON format for child is
that the image path is actually an
absolute path to the file from where the
editor and base file were formed so
effectively what this is saying is that
given the path to tiled there's some
really crazy file path to actually get
to the grits master PNG from the source
file we're using so to properly load
that what we'd like to do is strip out
all of the other data that's not just
the file name and then append the file
name to our data directory now this is
because our editing environment may be
in a different directory structure than
our production environment that users
are actually playing for grits we use
this nifty little regular expression
here that allowed us to replace all of
the data before the final slash with
blank characters giving us the file name
for this image we appended that file
name to the dot dot slash data directory
giving us the source